in russia basketball star brittany
griner was back in court today she
listened from inside a defendant's cage
as her lawyer submitted evidence in her
defense charlie dagetta has more on this
charlie good morning what's the latest
well good morning to you vlad well first
of all this is the first time we've seen
griner inside the actual russian
courtroom since pleading guilty to drug
charges last week she was handcuffed and
wearing a nirvana t-shirt she was led
into court this morning she had to duck
to enter the cage that cage is standard
in russian courts but shocking
nonetheless at one point she managed to
smile
she is facing drug possession and
smuggling charges she previously told
the court she accidentally packed
cannabis vape charges and had no
intention of breaking the law
today her lawyers gave evidence she has
permission to use um
medical cannabis in the united states
for chronic pain she faces a 10-year
sentence if found guilty the next
hearing is scheduled for july 26th tony
all right charlie daggett i got it
london thank you very much